hello my name is goldenrod hello hello
I'm Corey milcrest hi I'm our summer
Thomas I'm India armati fio and we are
the cast of Queen Charlotte Bridgeton
story and we're here to find out who we
really are
[Music]
first what's the quality you look for in
a best friend so we have loyalty honesty
optimistic good sense of humor kindness
supportive I'm going with supportive
good sense of humor oh it's in loyalty
that was the other one that I was going
to go before but yeah I'm going to go
with honesty I need to know who you are
which Bridgeton character would you
trust with a secret for the OG Daphne
Anthony Eloise Benedict Kate and Simon
Simon Simon oh that is tough in it it
would be Anthony Eloise or Benedict I'm
gonna go with Eloise
yeah that's me I've answered the same
yeah Eloise I don't know I would say
Benedict
he knows how to keep a really good
secret but he did get really drunk and
Spill the Beans didn't he and he was a
bit loopy is that word
he was a bit
there we go choose a theme for a party
you'd gladly attend a masquerade famous
horror characters that's a really good
one 70s disco okay these are all very
good old Hollywood Roaring Twenties and
Barbie
I would say 70s disco that feels like a
Freddy Krueger Freddy
very nice how are you I would do 70s
disco
were an afro and some role yes
yeah now pick a violin cover of a song
you'd want to dance to a ball and to
hear it by Taylor Swift Cafe by Beyonce
Let It Be by the Beatles I already know
who's picking that one Dreams by
Fleetwood Mac Toxic by Britney Spears or
good as hell by lizzo cuff it up baby so
does everyone here know all all the six
of those songs which one
four of them
yeah Taylor Swift
I didn't it's not over Beyonce you
picked up I might not be known uh
Beatles uh toxic
choose a Shonda Rhimes character to hang
out with for the day and we have Olivia
Pope Scandal Derek from Gray's Anatomy
annalize from How To Get Away With
Murder Maya from stations no no no
Oliver from How To Get Away With Murder
and Christina from Gray's Anatomy that's
a difficult one
you went Derek straight away yes no no
sorry sorry
no no no and you were wrong I was like
wow
yeah oh yeah that is true
oh gosh it is tough okay it'd be between
Olivia and Christina I feel like me and
Olivia could have like a big glass of
wine together you know and just like sit
on her nice DC couch yeah get all the
tea how big is this glass of wine like
it's like trademark that like the thing
is like the Goblet yeah pick something
to do to help you pass the time in the
Tom there we go firstly we have reading
second we have drawing third we have
stargazing let's see with the queen
playing piano and heck I wanted to duel
yourself be quite fun to have a little
bit of a
you know a bit of a jewel but maybe
stargazing oh boring oh okay fine right
heck I want a duel Bingo heck I want a
jewel that's mine as well I want a jewel
heck I want to read do you I want to
read and I want to keep on reading come
on come on you can see no drawings you
know the way that they do the artist
like community
okay and finally choose a book to movie
adaptation to watch so first Little
Women to all the boys I've Ever Loved
Before The Hunger Games The Devil Wears
Prada Pride and Prejudice and The
Princess Bride oh this is tough I know
mine really yeah what would you do Pride
and Prejudice
I've read it and I've watched it many
times the one with Matthew yeah I love
it you surprised me every day thanks
it's that hand foot is that hand Flinch
he does this little handful oh yeah that
was not written and it was improvised
but oh it's just
right yeah okay I would do either The
Princess Bride or The Devil Wears Prada
I'm doing Devil Wears Prada yeah good
ones that's old school man yeah that's
like old school dividend I would say
I've got to say The Hunger Games
because it's the only one where I've
read and watched it I think it did a
good job at accurately bringing the
words to the screen you know
okay sorry three one two one press
Ah that's so cool
oh my God I got really oh my god
[Applause]
did you get Violet Bridgeton yeah do you
know what actually I quite like that
your personality matches George you're
creative inquisitive and Charming like
George you're someone who loves to learn
about the world around you you're
thoughtful artistic and honest hush now
like violet your family is the most
important thing in the world to you and
you will do anything for them you're
kind supportive and loyal like brimsley
you're someone who will do anything for
the people closest to you your Fierce
loyalty and support are your strongest
qualities and the ones people admire
most about you you're ambitious
independent and resilient like Charlotte
you're someone who is a natural-born
leader and you are constantly pushing
yourself and those around you to be the
very best can we take that for the best
next press talk yeah that's great yeah
yeah that's a really good thing expect
from Charlotte yeah
goodbye thank you for watching BuzzFeed
and don't forget to watch Queen
Charlotte a Bridgeton Story on Netflix
thank you
[Music]